Germany's conservatives have had a rough
year Angela Merkel admitted that she had
demanded a lot of her party and she
warned that the struggle wasn't over yet
I cannot promise that things are going
to get easier because we must do what
these times demand of us she was
referring to her government's
controversial refugee policy which many
in her party questioned she said last
year's migration crisis must not be
allowed to repeat itself and she reached
out to critics by taking a hard line on
one touchstone issues we show our faces
in interpersonal communication that
plays a big role with us and that's why
the full-face bill does not belong here
it should be forbidden
wherever legally possible it does not
belong in our country Michel praised her
party and her own policies she called
for the continued support of the entire
CDU in the future even in difficult
times that the situation of the summer
of 2015 with it's acute humanitarian
emergency could nevertheless be dealt
with in the way it was dealt with and
that it could be organized and steered
this is something that will always be
remembered as our strong country's
crowning achievement of the Year 2015
delegates also applauded Merkel's
warnings about the surge in support for
right-wing populism without mentioning
the right-wing alternative for Germany
by name
she said such parties posed a threat to
democracy and to her party's claim to
power and she said she would need her
party's help to win the next election
and continue her conservative course
you